[Musique]
à l'audace et scor bénéficie à la faute
ces menaces font
[Musique]
bernard vallat
auj
[Musique]
d'accord mais
art
de start up
dans une fille
[Musique]
à prouver
cette équipe à causse
[Musique]
ocs vous êtes fan ou aussi
qu'est ce que vous foutez là
[Musique]
et
vous apprêtez à rencontrer un peuple
inconnu dans un pays ennemi inconnu
[Musique]
h&m a lâché plus de bon sur hambourg le
week end qui nous on est tombé sur
londres pendant toute la guerre
ça a été difficile pour toi aussi
j'imagine pour tous
cette maison est réquisitionnée pour
usage britannique josiane aubert
[Musique]
il ne faut peut-être pas démonstration
de leur haine mais elle est bien là sous
la surface
[Musique]
soyez prudents et où ils ne sont pas
connaître pendant la guerre vous est il
arrivé d'espérer la victoire de
l'allemagne
je voulais que tout redevienne comme
avant
me fait me manque les mortes dans les
bombardements
lewis tu ne m'avais pas du tout prévenu
ce n'était pas censé se passer comme ça
rien était censé se passer comme ça même
les pages d'aspe l'émission a exécuté
[Musique]
non
on
il
[Musique]
ça va aller pour nous on peut pas tout
recommence
nous avons commencé a commencé il a
répondu à une de vos lettres de fans et
à partir de là une correspondance
improbable a débuté et c'est pourquoi ne
pas remonter au tout début comment tout
a commencé entre vous et janet donovan
je venais d'avoir onze ans les élèves à
l'école se moquer de moi parce que
j'étais le petit nouveau
désolé ma mère et moi se parlent
pratiquement plus tous mes rêves s'était
envolé le seul qu'il avait survécu
c'était john on choisira l'impression
finale barbara ouais
un poney
ils avaient tous entre les mains
les femmes merci
la gloire l'amour je suis le gars le
plus sensé sur terre et c'est à ce
moment là que les gens commençaient à
s'interroger quelle était la vérité j'ai
écrit une lettre à john hess de nos
valises et à peu près cinq ans c'est
assez fou de ma part de penser qu'il
répondrait mais il l'a fait je n'ai que
11 ans mais je serai comme lui un jour
et on fera des films ensemble tu as
fabriqué la petite histoire non pas du
tout tu as menti et tu as menti pendant
des années l'industrie en dit c'est tout
actu oui ou non écrit des lettres à ce
gosse avez vous un correspondant un
correspondant aux enfants faites votre
boulot continuer
plus jamais tu écriras cet homme à
nouveau tu entends ce que dit
pourquoi les publier maintenant ça fait
12 ans et si ça pouvait changer les
choses ça parle de nous en tant que
société ce que nous voulons tous que
nous recherchons qu'est ce qu'un artiste
devrait révéler lui même et pourquoi est
ce que ça nous importe au juste je me
sens comme si j'avais tout fait rater si
jamais j'étais un imposteur après tout
peut-être que j'ai volé la place d'un
autre
mais la vraie question est comment
auriez-vous pu voler une place qui a été
fait juste pour vous maman plus beaux
restes et si cette librairie tu peux
rester ici pour le reste de ta vie
cher aux portes
je ne peux rêver d'un ami plus singulier
personne ne sera vraiment comprendre
notre amitié
jusqu'à ce que tu le leur permettent
[Musique]
la prose là